Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my bonus video I wanted to try and describe
each of The Doctor’s 13 Faces in the simplest
terms possible starting with William Hartnell.
1 - The Wizard
William Hartnell described his Doctor was
something of a cross between The Wizard of
Oz and Father Christmas.
I guess you could make a joke about Smoke
and Mirrors leading to unexpected gifts.
Paul McGann, the 8th Doctor described him
as having a very Victorian demeanor.
But I prefer thinking of him as a Wizard.
One of his most notable catchphrases was Come
Along My Dear.
His closest personal connection was to his
granddaughter Susan Foreman, but he had all
the idiosyncrasies associated with an old
man.
He had something of a mean streak in him and
was deeply mistrustful of outsiders.
Just like the Wizard of Oz, he eventually
softened and began to enjoy spending time
with his companions and did not want to go
when it was time to regenerate.
2 - The Clown
If the first Doctor had a much more victorian
personality, the second doctor swung to the
other end of the spectrum.
His catchphrase was “When I say Run, Run!”
He was still every bit as clever and manipulative
but he would often play the fool to defeat
enemies or just be plain funny.
He also panicked a lot despite being quite
heroic at all times.
I like to think of it as a precursor to “The
Doctor Lies”.
The Second Doctor was also really notable
for playing the recorder and his love affair
with hats.
Something Matt Smith’s Doctor took from
quite a bit.
3 - The Scientist
The Third Doctor was actually hired by Unit
as their Science Advisor.
So he was very literally a scientist.
During Jon Pertwee’s run, they constructed
a science lab standing set.
The Doctor had been exiled by the time lords
and had to look for a place on earth to haunt.
The First Doctor described him as a Dandy
because of his extravagant costume, but the
Third Doctor was far more physically active
than both of his previous selves.
Like he became the karate master.
During his run, he also became a master diplomat,
mediating disputes for the time lords.
One of his more notable catch phrases was
“Now Listen to me!”
He’s also one of the few Doctor’s to drive
a car.
4 - The Bohemian (Have a Jelly Baby?)
He was a genuinely warm and funny Doctor if
not just a little bit Manic.
I wouldn’t say manic depressive, but he
did have a much more cruel attitude towards
the Time Lords.
As the term implies, his costume and habits
were very adventuresome.
He wandered around more than any other Doctor.
Which technically isn’t fair, because he
got more episodes than any of the other Doctors.
His biggest catch phrase was “Have a Jelly
Baby?”
He was a lot more aloof than the previous
doctor’s, and given to brooding.
But I feel like he delivered some of the best
monologues in classic who.
He still retained a lot of the physicality
of the third doctor and even engaged in some
expert swordplay.
5 - The Pacifist
The fifth doctor was so against violence that
it eventually got him killed.
He was probably one of the most sensitive
incarnations and dropped a lot of the eccentric
behaviors of the fourth Doctor.
His biggest catch phrase was Sorry Must Dash,
but catch phrases in general weren’t as
prominent during his run.
Like I said, dropping a lot of the eccentricities.
Steven Moffat himself explained the Fifth
Doctor as being one of the most tortured,
maybe not as much as the 9th Doctor, but Peter
Davison conveyed a lot of the emotional problems
of the Doctor in his performance.
He was also one of the first boyish appearing
doctors, anachronistic to his extreme old
age.
6 - The Egoist
It may have been a result of his troubled
regeneration, but the Sixth Doctor had the
worst mood swings of any of the other doctors.
He was wildly egotistic and at the same time
compassionate.
His most notable catch phrase was “I Wonder,
Ah Ha!”
His costume of wild colors is a good indicator
for the changes in his moods.
Of all the Doctor’s costumes I feel like
his was one of the most polarizing.
Some feel like it was disastrous and some
totally love it.
7 - The Chessmaster (Not This Time…)
The seventh doctor brought back a lot of the
silly behaviors of the second doctor as a
way to misdirect people from his true intentions.
He was generally one of the more curious,
inquisitive and charming doctors.
And a consummate showman.
Something which I think Capaldi is also trying
to bring back.
One of his more notable catch phrases was
“Not This Time…”
He was a noted chessmaster, actually playing
chess.
But his adventures became an allegory for
a giant chess match against evil.
The actually had a giant chessboard in this
week’s episode.
8 - The Romantic (Who Am I?)
The Eighth Doctor was one of the most passionate.
And one of the first to actually kiss his
companion.
He suffered something of an identity crisis
post-regeneration and his most notable catch
phrase became “Who Am I?”
Because of his very short run on television,
he didn’t really get much of a chance to
develop as a character.
But the expanded material including the novels
and the audio dramas totally picked up the
slack.
Which is why everyone crapped their pants
when he showed up in the Night of The Doctor.
9 - The Warrior (No More…)
This was the dark doctor, we only saw him
at the very end of the time war, so most of
the supposed atrocities he committed in the
name of the Time Lords are left to speculation.
But they’re bad enough that all the newer
Doctor’s refused to mention his name.
His most notable catch phrase was “No More”
Steven Moffat said that he wrote John Hurt’s
Doctor thinking that the world was robbed
of a large period in the 90s when the show
was off the air.
During the story planning it’s said that
Moffat didn’t feel like the 8th Doctor would
have been the one to end the time war, it
just wasn’t in that character’s nature.
And he was pretty certain Christopher Eccleston
would decline any invitation to come back.
Thus John Hurt’s War Doctor was created.
It’s crazy to think that had Christopher
Eccleston come back, he would have gotten
the John Hurt storyline in the 50th Anniversary.
They would have had McGann regenerate into
Eccleston, then have eccleston detonate the
moment and escape in the TARDIS.
10 - The Survivor
The 9th Doctor was until recently, the last
survivor of the Time War, although Russell
Davies retconned that story so that the Master
and the Time Lords could come back.
Then the 50th also changed all of it again.
He was the PTSD doctor, given to violent outbursts
of joy and anger.
His most notable catch phrase was “Fantastic!”
Fans are still hoping that someday eccleston
will relent and come back for a future anniversary
special.
11 - The Human
The 10th Doctor was by far one of the most
human, even though the 8th Doctor started
the whole half human thing.
10 was just much more human in his emotinal
states and social habits.
He was also one of the more romantically attached
Doctors.
He even took the metaphor of being very human
to a literal place when he burned a regeneration
to create the metacrisis Doctor.
Who then went off to have his own set of adventures
with Rose.
He’s very cheeky but it all seems like an
act to hide this deep sea of anger and regret.
12 - The Raggedy Man
The old man in the very young man’s body.
The 11th Doctor was by far the most anachronstic
in his behavior and costuming.
Which might explain why he was so drawn to
helping children.
He brought back a lot of the eccentric moods
of the sixth doctor but did not include the
more obnoxious egotistical qualities.
His most notable catch phrase was of course,
“Bowties are cool”
and as we learned in Deep Breath, he yearned
for approval.
As evidenced by his young face.
13 - The Alien
Peter Capaldi’s 12th Doctor is still fresh
out of the gates, so a lot of his finer qualities
are still percolating.
But he is thus far the most Alien seeming
of all the Doctors.
Alien in his mannerisms and social habits.
He still possesses a lot of the pageantry
of the 11th and the seventh doctor with the
hard edge of the previous doctors.
He’s not quite as capricious as Matt Smith’s
Doctor got, but it’s still very early in
his run.
Give him time.
He doesn’t officially have a catch phrase
yet, but thus far “Shut Up” is the leading
candidate.
Now big challenge for you guys, describe as
many of the doctor’s as you can just using
one or two words.
I’m working on my Q&A next, so still plenty
of time to submit questions.
I’m not going to post it till Sunday.
The giveaway is still open too, all you have
to do to participate is be a subscriber and
leave a comment.
Feel free to leave suggestions for future
bonus videos.
My next one will post after the episode 7
review next week.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here for my episode 6 review.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and re-watch The Caretaker.